nous avons assisté dimanche à un nouveau
remaniement de votre gouvernement
il illustre un énième rétrécissement de
ce qui reste du maquereau nisme ou des
conseillers techniques ont été préférés
aux parlementaires de la majorité
il faut avis il faut dire que vous savez
bien vous entourer avec votre
gouvernement des copains il est temps de
sortir du grand débat par des mesures
concrètes
ces mesures nous les connaissons tous
elles doivent redonner du pouvoir
d'achat à nos compatriotes que votre
politique a lourdement sanctionné ces
deux dernières années avec les députés
les républicains nous vous avons formulé
des propositions simples et précises
réindexés l'ensemble des pensions de
retraites et des allocations familiales
sur l'inflation annulé la hausse de la
csg pour tous les retraités rétablir les
plafonds du quotient familial pour
soutenir davantage les familles aient
baissé de 10 % l'impôt sur le revenu des
français pour soutenir notamment nos
classes moyennes alors que seule une
véritable baisse de la dépense publique
permettrait de financer ces mesures de
bon sens vous continuez à matraquer
fiscalement les français à croire que
vous tenez au titre de champion du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires
vous avez en effet confirmé que les prix
de l'électricité augmenteront cette
année alors monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous accepter et je dis bien
accepté de débattre de nos propositions
de pouvoir d'achat attendue par les
français
la diminution du nombre de victimes
d'accidents de la route est un objectif
que tout le monde partage
nous connaissons tous des familles
endeuillées parfois décimée à cause de
l'alcool de la drogue ou de la vitesse
au volant
bien évidemment nous déplorons tous le
saccage de nombreux radars automatiques
la limitation généralisée de la vitesse
à 80 km/heure que vous avez imposées
sans concertation
l'an dernier n'a pas eu les effets
attendus en effet le nombre de morts sur
les routes a augmenté de 17,1 pour cent
en février avec 253 personnes tuées soit
37 de plus qu'en février 2018
depuis un an nous vous le disons la
sécurité routière ne peut se réduire à
un abaissement général de la vitesse car
les causes des accidents sont multiples
il est absurde monsieur le premier
ministre de fixer deux paris une vitesse
générale alors que les élus locaux qui
connaissent parfaitement leur territoire
sont les mieux placés pour décider au
cas par cas de la vitesse maximale qui
doit être autorisé monsieur le premier
ministre
allez vous enfin écouter les
parlementaires de terrain qui propose
une mesure équilibrée
répondant à la fois aux impératifs de
sécurité routière et aux préoccupations
de nos concitoyens qui en zones rurales
n'ont pas d'alternative à l'utilisation
des véhicules personnels pour aller au
travail à des rendez-vous médicaux ou
pour accompagner leurs enfants à l'école
d'ici la fin du quinquennat plus
personne ne paiera la taxe d'habitation
sans augmentation d'impôts a martelé le
président de la république
depuis cette annonce non concertée les
élus attendent vos propositions
le dégrèvement étant pour l'heure
financé par du déficit et donc de la
dette en octobre ont balancé son maire
avec mépris quelques semaines plus tard
les élus de proximité des devenu le
rempart de notre démocratie un pilier
sur lequel le gouvernement souhaitait
s'appuyer
alors que les communes aujourd'hui vote
leur budget et à moins d'un an des
municipal les élus ont besoin de
lisibilité de stabilité de confiance sur
l'évolution de leurs ressources pour
programmer leurs projets
la chose est d'autant moins aisée que
les annonces ont précédée la réflexion
sur la fiscalité et le financement des
collectivités
monsieur le ministre depuis l'annnonce
de votre réforme du lycée et du
baccalauréat le corps enseignant les
parents et les élèves sont inquiets et
tout particulièrement en zone rurale en
supprimant les filières
vous demandez aux élèves de construire
leur propre parcours professionnel dès
la classe de troisième celui ci devra
s'articuler autour d'un tronc commun
auxquels s'ajoutent trois spécialités en
classe de 1re puis deux en terminale
spécialité que les élèves devront
choisir parmi une douzaine proposés
d'aucuns pensent que ce choix est trop
important pour être réalisé par un élève
si jeune mais la plus grande crainte est
celle d'une nouvelle inégalité
territoriale
une fois encore une de plus madame la
ministre lundi matin la france la région
kitan la département de la haute garonne
et particulièrement la ville du lherm se
sont réveillés sous le choc
je souhaite d'abord apporter tout mon
soutien et ma compassion aux familles
endeuillées
ce que redoutait toutes les personnes
concernées par la dépendance et par
l'accueil réservé à nos aînés donnée de
se produire une crise sanitaire majeure
dans un ehpad une situation dramatique
avec le décès dans la nuit de cinq
pensionnaires et l'hospitalisation d'une
quinzaine de personnes
je ne reviendrai pas madame sur la
chaîne les dysfonctionnements qui a
conduit à ce désastre humain laissons la
justice faire son travail
vous insistez sur vous avait insisté sur
la volonté d'en comprendre les causes de
tirer les enseignements de ce tragique
événement mais madame la ministre nous
connaissons une partie des causes je
vous avertis c'est déjà au travers de ma
question orale tristement prémonitoire
du 12 février dernier le manque cruel
d'effectifs l'absence de revalorisation
des métiers du grand âge et de leur
rémunération
l'épuisement du personnel qui
régulièrement se mettant en grève tente
d'alerter sur les rythmes de travail et
dénoncent les conditions de prise en
charge de nos aînés
l'humain n'est plus au coeur de notre
mission d'accompagnement des personnes
âgées alors même que certains ehpad
génère des profits substantiels